when elon musk offered to buy twitter
for 54.20 cents a share or 43 billion he
said he was not playing the back and
forth game he was moving straight to the
end and this was his best and final
offer in the securities and exchange
commission filing a twitter's board
tried to stop him in his tracks by
adopting a so-called poison pill to make
it harder for musk to buy the company
under the structure shareholders are
allowed to purchase newly offered shares
at a discount except for the person
trying to acquire the company in this
case musk he'd have to purchase the new
shares at a higher price so it's a
measure to stop him from taking over
more shares of the platform as soon as
he hits 15
he currently owns 9
musk is said to be fighting back with a
plan of his own he is reportedly
speaking with investors who could
partner with him in his bid for twitter
one option according to the new york
post is to team up with private equity
firm silver lake's co-ceo egon durbin a
twitter board member who led musk's
effort to take tesla private the tesla
ceo is apparently also threatening to
appeal directly to shareholders he sent
out a cryptic tweet over the weekend
love me tender in reference to an elvis
presley song it could mean that he'll
bypass the board and invite shareholders
to sell or tender their stock to him at
a premium so they'll make a lot of money
what does he want with twitter in any
case i mean the guy already builds
electric cars and envisions trips to
mars given his professed mission to save
the world it may actually make sense if
his goal is to save the world in one way
or another he sees his purchase of
twitter as a way of saving democracy he
feels twitter is not living up to its
promise of being a platform for free
speech which he calls a societal
imperative for a functioning democracy
in the sec filing he said at a recent
ted event that a good way to tell if
free speech exists is to ask this
question is someone you don't like
allowed to say something you don't like
in the past few years twitter has
started fact checking and suspending
accounts it most famously banned donald
trump over his tweets surrounding the
2021 capital riots musk's patience with
twitter apparently ran out when it
suspended the account of new satire site
the babylon b which named u.s assistant
secretary for health dr rachel levine
its man of the year after usa today
named the transgender official one of
its women of the year babylon b's ceo
seth dillon said musk reached out to
confirm their account had in fact been
suspended dylan said musk even mused on
that call that he might need to buy
twitter purchasing his go-to social
media platform is certainly easier than
starting his own app which he says he
has seriously considered so what would
twitter look like under a new ownership
will the former president be welcomed
back we'll have to see during the recent
ted interview musk suggested bans should
be done with caution and that timeouts
are better than banning people
permanently he suggested that when it
comes to determining whether offensive
tweets should be removed the policy
should always be to let it stay when in
doubt so when in doubt leave it in don't
take it out musk has criticized
twitter's secret algorithm which it uses
to decide what to show you on your feed
he said the algorithm should be open
sourced so the public can inspect the
underlying code behind the algorithm to
ensure there's no manipulation behind
the scenes so basically you'd know
whether something was done to promote or
demote a tweet he wants an edit button
so people can revise their comments and
also wants to eliminate spam bots and
scam bots under his leadership ads could
be a thing of the past he has taken aim
at twitter's revenue model which relies
on advertising not everyone is happy
about an elon musk takeover including
some twitter employees and a saudi
prince and twitter shareholder musk shot
back by asking for the saudi arabian
kingdom's views on free speech the
country is known to crack down on
freedom of expression others were
reportedly already worried about him
joining the board let alone buying
twitter musk abruptly canceled his plans
to join the company's board which is
made up of the current twitter ceo barak
agrawal former ceo and co-founder jack
dorsey and independent directors in the
sec filing he stated i don't have
confidence in management a former sec
chair explained that joining the board
could have limited his influence jay
clayton told cnbc when you go on the
board of directors of a company your
degrees of freedom as an investor are
substantially restricted so instead of
joining the board he decided he wanted
to buy the whole shebang twitter has
over 200 million daily users two-thirds
of the size of the us population some of
its users have been described as woke an
ideology musk has blasted in an
interview with the babylon bee he said
wokeness basically wants to make comedy
illegal which is not cool trying to shut
down chappelle come on man that's crazy
he's referencing the attempt to cancel
comedian dave chappelle over transgender
remarks in his netflix special he
continued do you want a humorless
society that is simply rife with
condemnation and hate basically at his
heart wokeness is divisive exclusionary
and hateful it basically gives mean
people a shield to be mean and cruel
armored in false virtue while musk is
presenting himself as the king of free
speech others accuse him of hypocrisy in
february tesla employee john bernal said
he was fired from his job after posting
reviews critical of tesla's full
self-driving software on his youtube
channel ai addict in 2018 a blogger who
wrote not so flattering articles about
tesla said musk threatened to sue if he
continued writing articles so critics
don't see the richest man in the world
as a savior of free speech by the way
how on earth will he pay for it most of
his money is tied up in tesla stock
although he recently sold billions of
dollars worth of shares he had to pay
billions in taxes and he gave billions
to charity musk hired morgan stanley as
an advisor for the bid according to the
regulatory filing banks are often
brought on board to help with debt
financing having already become the
rocket man an electric car entrepreneur
a builder of tunnels and brain computer
chips he appears determined to be a
social media mogul as well he already
has the best and brightest engineers at
his disposal if twitter needed more
engineering chops if you'd like to brush
up on your science computer science and
math skills my sponsor brilliant has an
incredible website and app that makes
learning stem fun and it's super
interactive you can learn the key ideas
of computer science with their computer
science fundamentals course and no
coding is required it's great if you're
in high school or college and want to
learn the fundamentals or if you've
started your career and you like to
brush up on what you already know and if
you get the incorrect answer you can
click on the explanations to see where
you went wrong there's something for
everyone on brilliant including the
super fun logic courses that are my
personal favorite they really help
strengthen your analytical muscles to
get started for free visit brilliant.org
newsthink or click on the link in my
description or pin comment and the first
200 of you to click my link will get 20
off brilliant annual premium
subscription which unlocks all of the
courses thanks for watching for
newsthink i'm cindy
palm you